la disparitions massives d'oiseaux en
france l' alerte nous est venue de haute
montagne
il reste peut-être une dizaine de
couples de gypaètes qui reste
certainement moins d'une cinquantaine de
couples d'aigles royaux
une alerte qui remonte aux années
soixante dix
c'est des chiffres absolument ridicule
quand vous comparez de ça avec la
population il ya plus de 50 millions
d'hommes dans un pays comme la france
est en face d'eux ya peut-être même pas
50 couples d'aigles la cause première de
la disparition de rapaces à l'époque
c'est la chasse mais des gens 1970 un
autre coupable et identifiés l'action
plus indirecte c'est les pesticides les
pesticides ingérée par les insectes
mangés par les rongeurs ensuite chassés
par les oiseaux
l'empoisonnement par la chaîne
alimentaire les dégâts redoutés sont
largement constatée dans les années 2000
au point de menacer la survie de
certaines espèces exemple en 2009 avec
l'outarde une cousine de la perdrix en
déclin depuis 1984 et l'effectif est
passé de 7500 mal en france à moins de
300 aujourd'hui c'est le déclin le plus
spectaculaire à ma connaissance
enregistrés chez les oiseaux en europe
les oiseaux deschamps mais aussi des
villes le béton le manque de végétation
mais surtout la pollution
dans les années 2000 les spécialistes
parisiens alerter sur la disparition du
moineau dans la capitale on a fait le
calcul que c'était à peu près quatre
mille cinq cents moines ou qui
disparaissait par an si cette baisse
continue dans en 2050 on sera à peu près
au même niveau que londres c'est à dire
quasiment plus aucun moineaux à parle
sans oublier les espèces marines aussi
touchée par la pollution en bretagne par
exemple le macareux a vu sa population
chuter
ils étaient huit mille couples en france
dans les années 50 il en reste et 130 en
ça s'est accéléré avec les marées noires
la première a été terrible pour les
macareux le torrey canyon en 1967
et puis depuis 20 il ya eu d'autres
marées noires bien sûr mais il ya aussi
un déclin qui semble inexorable de cette
population qui la dernière colonie de
france métropolitaine le macareux
pourraient disparaître comme une espèce
d'oiseau sur huit dans le monde
en parallèle une note d'optimisme 25
espèces d'oiseaux ont pu être sauvé de
l'extinction
grâce à des mesures de conservation
[Musique]